previously on TV cents can I just say I
love your house it's just so tiny and
cute you remind me of my mother the
moment I saw you standing there in that
abortion of a dress
[Music]
guys hurry up the flight leaves in four
hours I could think tell him to get a
taxi there could be traffic the plane
could leave early when we get to London
there could be a line at customs come on
feels like the character development for
Monika throughout the series was just to
wind her up even tighter each season
like an overly obsessive and overly
cuckoo cuckoo clock I'm kind of
surprised in the series finale she
didn't just literally explode six-hour
trip to London that's a lot of Monica
funny I was just thinking the same thing
about a hundred and eighteen hours of
watching this show also Chandler is
probably right so what are they all
going on the same flight then I know
everyone's good buddies on this show you
may even call them mates or chumps for
pals but they don't have to do
everything together
the shot of Ross peeping out of the
fountain is just about as creepy as well
the Ross character in general why can't
you because I can't told you geez Ross
it's obvious you've been over this
before and you bringing it up now serves
as nothing more than a guilt trip
[ __ ] you're literally on your way out
the door to be fair how did chandler
expect pregnant Phoebe to hug him from
that angle wait what's with all the
kissing on the lips between friends
they're not even in Europe yet also is
this a thing that they've always done
and is there a compilation available
preferably in slow motion
holy GLAAD is a long lock Jane why is it
so long you could fit an entire human
body especially one of these cast
members through the opening of that door
if they use this chain even a sitcom
can't resist the sweet sweet siren call
of that one two cliche punch of showing
Big Ben and playing The Clash's London
Calling obvious has to obvious I guess
awesome I can't for the life of me think
of a show that has a greater disparity
in tone than the band that's featured in
one of its episodes wait okay that one
time The Flaming Lips played Beverly
Hills 90210 comes close but you get my
drift
oh hi mr. camera I guess you wanted your
establishing shop to also establish you
suck at avoiding reflections come on do
something I am I'm ignoring you just in
case you're looking for a way to make
the false laughter and your show feel
even full sir boy have I got an idea for
you keep using that irritating laugh
track even when you shoot on location
Emily honey oh that's that's timeout
still pretty aggressive gesture there
Rossi for a woman who is clearly a
little emotionally spent and stressed
out right before she's marrying you
seriously how does Ross get any women to
put up with it
oh hi camera track you know I'm starting
to get the sense that friends isn't used
to shooting on location
can't believe they're tearing it down
every is the most lovely building you'll
ever see I mean it's over I'm having a
hard time feeling bad for this wedding
falling apart when it appears they've
done absolutely zero research who did
you have permission to use this building
from wouldn't they have known to hold
off a couple days did you get a license
for its use I'm just saying this is 100%
on the crappy sorry happy couple man you
are Westminster crabby and this old
Chandler doesn't like to be videoed
b-story is Westminster shabby because
it's just a bunch of Westminster Gotti
and that makes the whole upper civil
Westminster flabby aah
sudden big Brinson you make me choose
between you and the hat I choose to hat
based on the way that Chandler has been
jammed luring it up to the nth degree
I think I might be with Joey here I'm
not gonna be embarrassed anymore
Chandler be any more of an [ __ ] to
that poor flower lady seriously you just
walk away without any help or even an
apology everybody in the show is a dick
little known fact this show held the
record for most dicks in one show up
until HBO released euphoria
it's Ross brushing a brush that just
seems a little more Monica than Ross but
you do you do you ask people to do that
Nate trousers Emily you call them
trousers you're gonna get your brick
cart revoked your lousy logic this is
the most positive yelp review KFC's
received in three decades even in 1998
London this is not how hotel room doors
work since the Millennials are confused
right now I'll clear it up before she
went on to sing with the Black Eyed Peas
Fergie was a red-haired English Duchess
you're welcome
and that pillowcase thing I thought you
guys were just doing the Flying Nun
sometimes we were well of all the things
you could do with pillowcases this
doesn't least seem fairly appropriate I
mean it really all depends on how much
Sally Field is involved wait where did
you get it from
dial-tone indicate you got hung up on
even though that's not how dial tones
work cliche you don't you're just gonna
mess with his head and ruin his wedding
you know Pheebs is making a lot of sense
here why does a show keep treating bad
relationship decisions as if they're
romantic and honorable and yes I know
Rachel will eventually decide to play
nice but if you don't think the show is
still wanting us to root for the
marriage not to work you're not paying
attention and I don't know if it starts
to rain we'll get wet
damn emily has a very specific fetish
selfies landlines and it is not polite
to make fun of people goodbye yeah but
if you took the making fun of people out
of friends it would be like taking the
sex scenes out of a porno there might be
a few moments left but hell if any of it
matters also June Whitfield is a
national treasure I mean it's a sin
because she's not our national treasure
but still man every beer old shot of
London in these episodes are of
double-decker buses and Big Ben there
are other things in London those Judy's
kids Judy the kids should have been the
friends version of that's what she said
or freezing but alas it never caught on
it's too late to make this happen
also now I'm confused as to what
actually made them late was it riding
the tube or riding the tube it's the
gallows dog well that's one and there
was another one man I would give all the
sins back if Jennifer Saunders were to
say it's absolutely fabulous to meet you
damn it Edina you had one job we know
how expensive weddings can be besides
this may be the only wedding we got to
throw is it though because Ross has been
married before he has a son to prove it
and everything the chauffeur gets
ongoing plotlines more often than lost
Jesus between this and Phoebe mimicking
Emily's housekeeper on the phone these
friends are becoming even ruder than
those Seinfeld's they better be careful
or they might end up in the worst series
family ever jail for the rest of their
lives
gazebo goodbye Judy the kids see it
works yeah well if you wanted roses best
friends why aren't you here
I can't fly I'm having my brother's
babies they were already diving deep
into incest jokes by season four man
guess the next 100 plus episodes are
gonna be getting into some dark terrain
at least they'll never do anything like
Ross as a professor dating one of his
young students
God that'll never happen oh come on
Moneyball let's make a deal
new people all right forget it
congratulations family that got a clap
that got a clap
what's this live audience stolen from
the Phil Donahue set because those would
clap for goddamn everything look we're
down to just one point could we please
maybe just settle it after the wedding
it seems like what should have been said
and likely would have been said as soon
as the whole thing came up but you're
the one who went all negotiator on this
thing Ross so you only have yourself to
blame oh and the necessity for lame
sitcom B stories you think you know I
was here you know at their heart humans
just want to see everybody they love
everybody else they love it's really
super sweet
Kawai Eric Ling's if you're planning on
doing that throughout the entire flight
please tell me now so that I can take a
sedative I'm a little worried about this
character actor Hugh Laurie don't want
him to get typecast as a sarcastic smart
[ __ ]
also this show might as well have been
called the one with the famous British
actors that Americans only knew in 1998
if they watch PBS I'm now assuming the
wedding band will be the cast of our
being served it wouldn't be an episode
of Friends if someone didn't yell all
their lines yeah I just want to say that
you our horrible horrible puss the dad
from Stuart little would be excellent at
TV since well I think you're wrong
oh no I'm by the way it seems to be
perfectly clear that you were on a break
okay that might have actually earned the
laugh track you could say she has a
sixth sense about him yeah yeah yeah
I'll send myself out um it's the stewed
seriously scratching his drum British
drugs must be bitching I'm walking down
the aisle and now I'm at the front with
Ross it's Phoebe
you know how sitcoms will have
characters do absolutely ridiculous
things that no human would ever do just
because they think it's funny is there a
limit to that asking for a friend's as I
surveyed this crowd I have to ask
where's Ross's son the show gave us an
incessant number of establishing shots
of Big Ben but can't afford to bring
over a little bit I'm Ross take the
Emily take the rage so shall I go on
nope just stand there for about three
months while we wait for the next season
to start clipping hangers wait that
gentleman on the phone he lorries
character wasn't on the phone one
goddamn time during this episode you
think with all the money friends made by
the fourth season they could afford
someone to proofread the credit copy and
correct this to claim
wait you got the wrong guy my name's
Simon London maybe okay cuz that's not
gonna get it away yeah baby hands down
best Abbey I ever seen
so what are you fine gentlemen in the
market for would you like to buy a
monkey well how'd you get the beans
about the Frank New York to me again
forget about it so how you doing how you
doing
kill you with my thumb banging your head